[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Lining a
cooking or baking pan
with culinary parchment
paper instantly
makes cleanup a whole lot
easier because nothing
sticks to the pan.
With parchment paper, there's
no need to grease the pan
with messy butter or oil.
This culinary
parchment paper comes
in a standard sheet roll or an
assortment of specialty shapes.
It's heat resistant to a
temperature of 450 degrees.
Making paper begins with pulp,
which is pulverized wood.
This parchment-paper
manufacturer
uses eucalyptus because
it's a sustainable resource.
They mix the pulp with water
in a huge industrial mixer.
This special recipe
of eucalyptus fibers
produces tan-colored paper.
Once the consistency
is just right,
they pump the soggy
pulp out of the blender
and into a machine
that spreads it
evenly across a metal
mesh belt. The water
drains through the
openings in the mesh.
By the time the pulp
rolls into the first term
of the next machine, it is
formed into a sheet of paper.
Sprayers rehydrate what's
trimmed off the edges
so it can be recycled.
The paper travels through a
long line of heated rollers.
They squeeze out the remaining
water and dry the paper.
A high-resolution scanner
looks for imperfections
as the paper exits the machine.
Workers unwind the bolt and
conduct a visual inspection
against backlighting.
Next, the bolt
undergoes the first
of two critical operations which
transforms this regular paper
into culinary parchment paper.
First, the sheet passes
through two baths
in a proprietary
water-based solution.
This eliminates air
pockets and renders
the paper heat resistant.
After a series of
rinses, another long line
of heated rollers squeezes
out the rinse water
and dries the paper.
The next station
sprays both sides
of the sheet with
food-grade silicon,
then bakes on the coating
in a gas-fired dryer.
Silicon withstands heat
up to 1,500 degrees.
So even at the highest
cooking temperatures,
there will be a barrier
that prevents food
from sticking to the paper.
Silicone also repels water.
This is the paper
before the treatments
make it heat resistant,
nonstick, and waterproof.
And here's how
the paper performs
after those treatments.
Because it's
waterproof, you can wet
the paper to make it
malleable enough to line
a pan of any shape.
The factory cuts the
bolts to consumer widths,
then shrink wraps and ships
them to factories that supply
restaurants and supermarkets.
Here, machines unwind
the bolts, then
wind specific lengths
of parchment paper
onto cardboard tubes.
Winding a 165 foot roll
takes just three seconds.
The factory also applies
its logo to the paper
at regular intervals.
However, that operation
is top secret.
The automated packaging
equipment tapes down the edge
to prevent unraveling,
then places and seals
the roll in a cardboard box.
The machine stamps the
box with a lot code.
So if a problem
arises, the factory
can trace the roll
back to the large bolt
from which it originated.
This parchment paper, cardboard
tube, and box are all made
from sustainable resources.
The box edge is rigid
enough to tear off a sheet,
so there's no need
for an unrecyclable
metal cutting edge.
You can throw the used parchment
paper in your compost bin
or rinse off the
food remnants and put
it, along with the box and
tube, in your recycling bin.